[Music]
the limits of this conflict are being
stretched by the day how far was laid
bare by these pictures overnight
missiles targeted a ukrainian nuclear
plant the biggest of its kind in europe
ukraine dismissed russian claims that
this was an act of self-sabotage the
ukrainian president warned of
implications far beyond his country's
borders
russian people i want to appeal to you
how is this possible
after all we fought together in 1986
against the chernobyl catastrophe
consequences
you must tell your authorities take to
the streets and say that you want to
live that you want to live on an earth
without radioactive contamination
radiation does not know where russia is
analysis of the attack on the zebra zaya
plant revealed there was no leak of
radioactive material the plant remains
safe for now
it's important to say that all the
safety systems
of the six reactors
at the plant were not affected
at all
and that there has been no release of
radioactive material
no release of reactive material
the attacks on ukraine's infrastructure
take place in tandem with missile
assaults on its towns and cities
this footage shows turkish aid workers
dealing with the aftermath of an
airstrike near key
the destruction and the displaced
pictures from the air show the
devastation on the ground
these are apartment buildings in
borobayanka 50 miles from the capitol
sky news has verified and located this
video to jitomir 90 miles west of key
russia's defense ministry released these
pictures of what it says or destroyed
ukrainian military vehicles
ukraine says that troops from belarus
have now been given the signal to join
the russian military advance
as they move in ukrainians move out a
constant exodus of refugees continues to
safety beyond its borders
in kosovo and the polish border they
played piano by way of a greeting a
welcome sound ahead even if it can't
drown out the drum beat of war behind
[Music]
james matthews sky news